is japanese tick tock good
no because because right and i know
good i'm going to say this right i'm
going to say this
i'm going to say this right now right
before people [ __ ] accuse me yeah be
like oh this is what the content gives
you blah blah blah i downloaded tik tok
right yeah fresh account yep first thing
i open it right so it knows i'm in japan
it's automatically japanese it's
automatically japanese
what do you think comes up and i'm
scrolling for a while what do you think
comes out um
well my experience yeah from my
experience it's just a lot of like
japanese girls dancing god damn it
that's all it was yeah that's all it is
literally japanese women right yeah and
yeah they're very beautiful very
attractive yeah not even dancing just
like moving their arms they just like
and they normally have
they are normally
they normally have um assets that are
bigger than normal yeah and
that was all it was i scrolled through
like 50 tick tocks and maybe out of the
50 i i i didn't pause any of them i'm
just scrolling brand new account nothing
all it knew was that i was probably male
i'm guessing get me that from the app
store yeah yeah and
that's all it was yeah like you'll enjoy
this type of content or a japanese mail
and i was just like
don't get me wrong there is a time and a
place for this yeah i don't want this
yeah this is not what i want i want to
see the means i'm not the kind of person
all right i am i am i don't know if this
is like a
sigma male grind set
i don't want to hate how you said that i
don't wanna
i don't want to see like
women or something
that's not so bad
i don't wanna see women i don't wanna
see [ __ ] that is trying to make me horny
when i'm not horny right if i want to
watch stuff like that i'm just going to
go and watch porn
it's very obvious what audience that is
am i allowed to say that that's like
women just dancing and showing off boobs
i mean it's always it's been like that
since the beginning of probably time i'm
fine with that content yeah but i don't
want that most of the time yeah i mean
there's
so much of that kind of content you can
consume
it's the same it's the same reason why
you know everyone hated the old remember
when like youtube went through this
epidemic of the reply girls yeah where
it was just you know girls you know with
scans
you know obviously i i you know have
absolutely nothing against people who
want to make that content no exactly uh
you know i support uh all that stuff and
any sex workers you keep doing what you
want to do man i wish there was more
protection around stuff like that
obviously this isn't very different
but it's just for me personally most of
the time when i see that stuff i i'm not
the audience they're trying to appeal to
because i don't want to that doesn't i
don't see that stuff and i'm not like oh
this is the content i want to see right
well you're awesome you're also not a
horny teenager anymore right right to me
it's like as someone who is 25 um i you
know i'm doing my own thing what not to
me when i see a girl dancing as a
content creator i'm just like okay what
am i what am i following for here yeah
what am i
if i if i want to follow this cradle
what am i what am i coming back for yeah
yeah to watch them dance
like when it's not even different it's
like
they do this [ __ ] same thing every
time right they just go like this
yeah
it's like your 50 year old on at a
wedding you know yeah it's just it's
just the bare minimum movement and it's
like this is dancing right right i i got
this conversation respectfully sounds so
sexy i'm not trying to be i don't know
it's just it's not it's not the content
we personally want to see right that's
that's that's not even like the worst
kind of like
likes
i don't know what the genre is but like
the sleaze bait or whatever i don't even
know what the genre is like i've like i
remember seeing it's obviously sexual
and it's going to appear and anyone like
who sees that video says it's not sexual
it's a complete [ __ ] oh it is
absolutely who you're appealing to i
mean it's very obvious that like at
least in japan and i actually with the
rest of the world too that like the main
demographic of tick tock is like teenage
boys and girls right so obviously
what what are teenage boys going to
enjoy sorry i don't trust you that kind
of sleeps because i remember like the
other trends that i saw on tiktok was um
it was like
girls who are obviously you know
very confident and uh you know
trying to uh know what was i was i can
say it was girls
that had this audio that played which
was person no no no no no it was like
that was a good one if we had 24 hours
with me alone oh that would and i
couldn't say no
what would you do
and i'm just i'm just like like most of
the memes i've seen of that are like
parodies of that but that just means
that there are enough people they're
doing this unironically yeah to to like
well you're already in the first place
right that's why like it's been parodied
so much because it is so saturated and
is such it's baked it's such it's such a
sleaze for you right you know and um i
this is a new coffee yeah let's give
this a taste coffee game trash table
coffee cake
fresh cheese coffee
is it battle still tastes funny i don't
know what's happened there's something
offensive i'm not offended but i'm like
come on man just because i i log on the
platform you got to show me this [ __ ]
yeah yeah at least at least give me
something else to look at so you can
kind of figure me out
give a little bit of variance right in
the context why are you gonna what are
you gonna assume what i'm into man like
yeah she's beautiful good for her i'm
glad she's killing i'm glad she's got 20
million views every goddamn second good
for her why did you assume i was into it
no but that's the thing right it's like
i wouldn't even be mad if it was just
you know popping up every now and then
right it's like yeah of course you know
it has to appeal to that demographic but
like yeah i had the exact same
experience when i opened it it was like
49 out of 50. yeah which is a different
girl i'm not excited i want to be like
headline
man gets mad that woman is dancing
like that's not it but also but like a
little bit of variance doesn't hurt
anyone right it just means like you the
algorithm hasn't been tailored for you
exactly exactly
but that's that's just like i kind of
said that that's what it was like that
if if you were a new user in japan yeah
and i assume they know my age and maybe
my my gender well it just it just means
like our algorithmically yeah that is
the content
that works
apparently and i'm guessing it's because
there's a certain age range and a
demographic that the algorithm puts you
in yeah and they're just like this
person wants to see
this kind of content you want to see you
want to see horny content we got you
right and i mean it's it's it's
everyone knows sex cells and it's always
been that like that since the beginning
of now i just very much like my horny
separate from my my life yeah
i like it i like when i sold that to the
man who likes hentai twitter
i see i i can i can look at hentai right
and i can i can just be like nice but i
don't feel anything towards it but when
i'm like all right i'm now i'm going to
jack off then i'm like all right what do
you think i'm jacking off to everything
i like no no no no no no no
i'm just like i'm scrolling through
no like i don't know yeah no but i'm the
same right it's like i don't like all
these like anti-picks on twitter because
i'm [ __ ] feeling horny i'm just like
oh that's cool artwork i i think i don't
know really this why why is it because
when you see hentai you're like you're
in you're unoffended by it but sometimes
you can see someone uh trying to be sexy
and it can be annoying i don't know
because you're like well i i i think
it's the difference between just someone
trying to be sexy and someone who's done
put art into it right because yeah i i
think i think the same way except when i
see like a [ __ ] amazing cosplayer for
example right i love singing like i love
seeing great cosplay even if some of
them are like very suggestive it doesn't
matter because someone put work into
this someone did a [ __ ] photo shoot
and it was [ __ ] great you know and i
feel like that is the difference between
just
like seeing hentai or you're like really
sexy cosplays on your timeline versus
just seeing
you know uh i don't i don't know what's
it like sleaze bait i'm just gonna call
it yeah yeah
no i i get that i get that i mean
cosplay is amazing and there's plenty of
lewd stuff out there that uh i enjoy but
that's why i like twitter because you
can you can get like 50 memes and a
bunch of loot stuff all in the same
place right there's variants yeah yeah
yeah maybe if i use tok more and it
figured out that i liked some other
stuff
i don't know why i was just kind of like
uh
oh i know and every ad in japan is like
that as well i don't know if it's japan
it might be just japan that's like this
but like every ad i get in japan as well
is like porn like dating sites yeah it
is literally like the number one ad that
i get on twitter is this one website
where you can hire girls to speak to you
oh i've seen that one and i get it yeah
all the time yeah yeah and i'm just like
this is sad that this is like the number
one thing yeah i mean that's a whole
nother thing about loneliness in japan
yeah yeah
guys i i genuinely don't even think like
even after it gets tailored like
that that that will go away